All the rest is interpreted by us.
Computation only exists relative to consciousness.
Either a conscious agent is carrying out the computation,
or he's got a piece of machinery that admits of a computational interpretation.
Now that doesn't mean computation is arbitrary.
I spent a lot of money on this hardware.
But we have this persistent confusion
between objectivity and subjectivity as features of reality
and objectivity and subjectivity as features of claims.
And the bottom line of this part of my talk is this:
You can have a completely objective science,
a science where you make objectively true claims,
about a domain whose existence is subjective,
whose existence is in the human brain
consisting of subjective states of sentience
or feeling or awareness.
So the objection that you can't have an objective science of consciousness
because it's subjective and science is objective, that's a pun.
That's a bad pun on objectivity and subjectivity.
You can make objective claims
about a domain that is subjective in its mode of existence,
and indeed that's what neurologists do.
I mean, you have patients that actually suffer pains,
and you try to get an objective science of that.
Okay, I promised to refute all these guys,
and I don't have an awful lot of time left,
but let me refute a couple more of them.
I said that behaviorism ought to be
one of the great embarrassments of our intellectual culture,
because it's refuted the moment you think about it.
Your mental states are identical with your behavior?
Well, think about the distinction between feeling a pain
and engaging in pain behavior.
I won't demonstrate pain behavior, but I can tell you
I'm not having any pains right now.
So it's an obvious mistake. Why did they make the mistake?
The mistake was — and you can go back and read
the literature on this, you can see this over and over —
they think if you accept the irreducible existence
of consciousness, you're giving up on science.
You're giving up on 300 years of human progress
and human hope and all the rest of it.
And the message I want to leave you with is,
consciousness has to become accepted
as a genuine biological phenomenon,
as much subject to scientific analysis
as any other phenomenon in biology,
or, for that matter, the rest of science.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)